Let's
[music]
work with the the pull. Okay. So, you're
you're you're trying to pull away. Okay.
Yeah.
Okay. Don't go flying unless you have
to.
That would be a have to, right? Okay.
You just you don't you don't have to
necessarily resist so much, but you're
you're not going to move. I'm going to
move you. Okay. Yeah. And that's all.
See, you can stop moving. You see that?
>> So, that's what I want today. Okay.
Boom. And I keep moving you.
You can uh Yep. Stop. Yep. Stop. Okay.
And you could pull again if you want.
Okay. And I use the pull.
Yeah. You can always every time you can
pull against it. And I work with the
pull.
Good. Yep.
>> Do you understand the little rules of
the game?
>> Yes.
>> So, I will always move you and then you
can stop and then start the pull again.
Yes. Exactly. Okay.
pull again if you want. Yep. Every time.
Do it again.
Yep.
Good.
Okay. Okay.
Okay. Try. Okay. So, uh, look at my
hands, Virginia. Okay. So, not I'm not
trying to get trying to advance. Okay.
All right. [clears throat] So, I stick.
Got it. She's trying to pull. She's
trying to not fall. So now when you go,
if I just keep pulling, she should be
able to keep stepping. Do you see?
She'll just keep stepping.
So once you get her there, then that
foot has to be pinned. Do you feel that?
You see?
>> So try try to step on that foot.
>> Do you see? Yes.
>> Okay. It's not that she stops. She takes
her step, then she stops stepping. And
now she pivots on that foot. She She uh
boom. That foot is now pinned.
And then I can use that. Okay. So, first
thing, touch wherever. Touch wherever to
get that going. There's that foot pin
right there. Don't fall yet. Okay. Stay
in the fight.
>> Then the third thing is as she's trying
to pull, right? Don't pull against it.
Just like if she was trying to push,
turn the pull. So she tries to pull,
turn the pull. Okay.
So here, there's that foot. So that's
the foot I use. They're pinned. Okay.
Now I turn.
Okay. Try.
>> I'm the UK. Okay.
>> So I She She's going to stick to me. I'm
the UK. Good. Okay. See, I can go like
this. Okay.
>> Wait. If you do that on me,
>> you're going to get even more stuff.
>> Okay. So then I wouldn't do
then I wouldn't do it on me, but I might
do it on her. Okay. Uh
she she uh uh pushes.
You see?
>> She pulls
If she pushes, I'm not going here. If
she pulls, I'm not going here. Do you
see that? I just trading which foot the
ground the energy is going to. So when
she pulls, it goes to the front foot.
When she pushes, goes to the back foot.
Do you see that? So not not my
line of gravity for pull. She pulls.
It's in the back. When she pushes, it's
in the front. I'm not doing that. I'm
just shifting. Okay. Just shifting. Just
shifting where I'm at. And I go
front foot. Not here. Front foot.
Back foot.
Okay. Try it again. Got it.
Okay. So, you're you're pulling. You see
the stalemate?
>> Like it were here. I I start turning it.
>> Hi.
>> Do you see?
>> Okay. And then I try to pin it.
>> Hi.
>> Okay. And if I pin that foot
just like I can make you pick up the
back foot. Do you see?
>> But you'll be able to put the back foot
down and then change the pin on the
front foot. If I There's the pin on the
front foot.
>> Right. put the back foot down and move
the front foot now. Do you see that?
>> Okay. So, that's just because you stayed
on that pin.
>> So, as you go to move, I keep doing it.
>> Do you understand?
>> And then it's easier. So, uh, start
turning it. There's the pin on that
foot. Do you get it? [snorts]
>> You're pulling right home. There's the
turn. And right when you go there, I
take advantage of that. Okay. as opposed
to let you get that. So when you go
I could do it here or I could do it here
>> when you go one foot. Okay. But you have
to stay in it. Okay.
You're going here. Okay. So right when
here like I turn. Okay. So you you you
to turn one part has to either not move
and the other part has to move or one
part can move slower than the other part
moving faster than you'll turn. Do you
see that? I move both parts together
it's not going to happen. Okay. If I go
here because you keep resisting this
technique we just are changing the
relationship. That's all we're doing.
Okay. So to get the spiral rotate at the
beginning, one side either stops, the
other side turns there. There's the
turn. Do you see? Okay. And now you work
with whatever they're doing on you.
Okay. So we're back where we started.
Right.
>> Right. Did you see that? So I go one
boom. And as you do that, I take you
further in. Do you see? Okay. And then
now, this is what always happens is as
you try to not fall, you now stopped
pulling and you're now pushing on me. Do
do you see that? And so that's what I
use.
>> Okay. But you have to be sensitive to
it.
>> So one side moves the other one moves at
a different rate. Do you see?
>> Okay. And we're going. There's that
step.
And you
Boom. There it is.
Good. Let you have it if you come up.
Good. Cool. Go in this way. So, you see
that one?
Go back here or over here. No, you were
there and you felt that one coming,
right?
>> So, you pushed and [snorts] I go here
and we're over here now. See?
And then you felt you push on me.
Boom.
There it is.
Then if they hyper yin yield, you'll
take the spine time. Do you understand?
Okay. So, we're coming in here,
right? And then you go in this way and
disarm yield.
>> Do you see? So, then you take the spine
line.
Okay.
You have to feel all that. So, boom.
Can step if you want. Change it. Pin the
foot to it's too low for you to do
anything with the stepping. You can do
that.
Boom.
There you are pushing.
>> You see
there's the yin yield.
>> There's the head.
Okay.
[laughter] So, right that it's just like
an attack. If I push, you turn it.
>> So, I pull. Yes.
Yes.
So go back when I pushed cuz you had my
balance. That's when you yielded. Good.
[snorts] Turn it.
Yes.
Lower it. So stick. Stick. And if you go
here, you'll lower it. Good. And then
I'm pushing. And you push.
You have to resist the urge to push back
on me.
Turn it. You can always step if you
don't like it.
Good. There's the push.
Well, that set us back up. Do you see?
You always have to spiral rotate.
So, think of it. You're resisting that.
Do you see that?
>> Can Can you go somewhere where you're
not pulling back on it?
[snorts]
>> [laughter]
>> This is what you feel like. Go.
>> I'm just pulling.
>> Yeah. You're just pulling on. So what
you watch watch what I do. Look how
you're pulling there. Got it.
>> Okay. So go back
as you go there. I go here.
You see?
So just enough of a change.
That's not what you wanted. You wanted
that.
>> Right. So as you go to pull, this goes
there. Then we're changing.
So I go to pull
outward spiral. There it is. And here it
is right here. Do you see?
>> See the turn
>> height.
>> Okay.
So don't try to overpower it.
>> Turn around it. Do you understand?
>> Height.
know my balance is back.
There's the push.
Then you kneel spine.
Back to the limb. Head.
Limb.
Head and limb.
Feel
that difference?
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
So, go a little slower.
Here's that pull.
Good. Don't push down. See, you smell
leverage. Do you understand?
>> Cuz you feel your skeletal alignment.
>> Hi.
>> So, you want to drive on it. You want to
drive on it.
>> I should drive on it.
>> You want to I want you to do what you
wanted to do.
>> There's your power. You see?
>> Yes.
>> The only problem is go drive on it.
>> Is that I can rebound and ground. So,
it's not there.
It's not there.
So here out [snorts] and you smell this.
Do you see that?
>> Go boom. I'm not going to do that. I
just using it. Using it.
Turn it
in. field head.
So try to grab my head so you
understand. Grab my head from the UK.
See?
Try to grab my head.
Did you feel the yield before it? That's
what you're do because you're trying to
get out of it. Don't go out of the
the frying pan into the fire.
Okay. Now, don't smell that.
>> Just use it to pin the foot. You got it.
No, it's pinned.
It's pinned.
>> Right. In the instant you push, it got
pinned.
>> So, in the instant you pin it, turn it.
Turn it here. Don't turn here.
Pin turn. Yes, you got it.
>> Go back and don't expect that to fall.
>> So guys pulling pin the foot. Good.
That's it. Okay. Now see what they do.
Trying to get his balance this way. Do
you see?
Good. Push again. Don't. No. Too far.
All you need is the pin.
>> Right.
>> Boom. He moved. He's gonna do it again.
You got to get it before [laughter] he
does it.
>> So, let me show you. Okay, there's the
pin. There's the push.
Pin push. Got it. I go in this way. I
don't go here. It's just pin push.
You got to carefully not to yin yield.
Good. Good.
Oh, [laughter]
that's it. That's all I need right
there. Right turn. That's it. Yin yield.
Your yin yield is the same desire to
fight. You're trying to win too much.
Yes.
>> Okay.
Go.
There's the desire.
You're fighting.
You're pushing.
You never had it. [laughter]
>> [laughter]
[gasps]
>> Let's stop making a contest. Okay. So,
we'll just do drills. Okay. Uh
pull. Okay. Got it.
Shift this foot.
Pressure on the foot.
>> That foot. We'll go again.
You're doing that
with you.
I'm going to turn.
Turn. That was it. Okay. [snorts]
Ready.
Turn. Don't cut. Just rest. Just rest.
Just rest. That was it.
Don't push down.
You okay?
Pay attention which way my hand is
going.
Watch. Is it going
west or east?
>> East.
>> Change.
[snorts]
Which way is your hand going?
You don't want to come this way. Come
this way. Yes. That was it.
Yes.
Find my foot as light as possible.
Little too light. Too light.
Too light. F. Connect my foot. So,
here's what I mean. Okay. So, uh, as
you're going in, uh, stay where you are.
Okay. This is where I'm pushing here. Do
you see? Okay. But not here.
>> But not here either. Okay, it's in the
center. So, I can have the center. So,
we have to feel my center.
Center. Find my There it is. Okay. And
do it again.
Good.
You're kind of going that way. Go into
the center. Yes. And it's not about it's
it's about energy, not anatomy.
Okay. Stay there. Can you move me to
your right? Then you get enough
connection there. It's not about down.
It's in.
There you go. Okay.
Find my center
and go ahead and move it.
Stay. Stay. Not anatomy. You don't You
don't need to get over here to move it.
>> It's It's enough here.
Move it. Yes. Good.
Now you get there. Move it. Move it.
You want to do anatomy. You want to go
like this.
This
you can always use your other hand.
Okay. If if you know if it's like it's
too slippery because we're sweating or
whatever. Okay. Or you double your
friction. But don't don't now go here
and then try to do that. Okay.
Connection. See how you're on the
outside
on top. Good.
Wait for the queue.
More here, less around me.
Sure. Use it. [snorts]
Don't fight it.
Yep.
Okay, try in this point. Okay, so uh you
have a lot of this
>> and then this hand is doing this. Do you
get it?
>> And so if we had a glass table, they're
not This might be like a few inches off.
Do you see that? So it looks like you
want this hand to go up
>> and in.
>> Okay.
>> And towards
>> Do you see?
>> Okay. Well, then this hand will go out
>> down. Do you see? And towards me.
>> Hi.
>> And then you get the bigger effect on
you.
bigger effect on you because more of the
universe is working upon you and not
just aspect of it. Okay? All right. So
that's what I mean. Okay? That if I get
these things going, do you get it? So,
let's push push really hard on this
hand. Do you see that? Well, this one is
now in a yin phase.
I don't know why. And I don't care why.
Okay. So, the other we do the other one.
We'll get there again. Okay. And now
lift up really high on that hand. And
your instinct is to shove down here. But
now this one goes in. Do you get it? So,
you already know that. So when you feel
the the force in your own body
stop and you go to the other hand it
will be in the yin phase. Okay.
>> Okay. If you can't feel it you should be
able to feel it but if you can't feel it
you can cosmogonically
map it that she's she's pulling you. Do
you get that? And you try to do
something on one hand but now you left
that hand dead. Do do you you're you're
being cosmogonically mapped. So as you
did something with one hand, that hand
went yong and this hand went yin.
So you didn't do anything with it.
>> So as she goes to pull in, you're always
doing something with the two hands
together. Always doing something.
Don't get f focused. Usually what
happens is she pulls and you feel one of
them's ticking your balance more than
the other one. So that's the one that
you focus on. And this hand went dead.
>> So she's going, you can see how this
elbow's anchored more. Do you see that?
So I feel my b I feel my line of gravity
being taken that way. Okay. So again,
that's only a problem if you're not
grounding because if you are grounding,
go ahead. My line of gravity never
moves. Okay. But if should that happen,
then you this is where your attention
goes. You'll feel that it's very yin.
It's like she didn't even have anything
on the other hand because she was being
cosmogonically mapped and she
overemphasized one hand gave me the
other hand. Okay. But if you're
grounding it's a moot point got there.
So we'll use you again. Okay. So you're
you're uh going here and that's where
you felt that. Do you see that?
>> It's it's this relationship that's in
the yongface. Do you got it? So is she
as she's here when I go here do you see
it's not in a young face.
So come back
the other thing you can do is with your
body. Okay. So you you got here like
that and then you're pulling that out.
Do you see that? Okay. So the reason
that you're pulling that out is because
it's relationship to your center. My
center is on the is on the other side
and the active qua
can't get to push on there. So you can
get it to where you want it to be. And
look how I shifted weight. Do you see
that? Okay. And now my body's not
pulling it on the outer deltoid.
>> So you're you're over here and you're
trying to pull it across.
>> I yan move the other side and then you
rotate the qua
and it goes
yin again. Okay. So the hands are yin
and yang to each other. The hand is yin
and yang to each other. And the hand is
the arms are yin and yang to what my qua
and center is doing. Okay. Well, it's
not important, but Marshi, you want to
always think about that. Um, let's say
she's in that in this stance. Do you see
she's in Ihan, me? Uh, if you take her
to this to this way, she'll always be
able to step into that. Do you see? If
you take her the other way, then you get
her outside that edge. She has that
awkwardness. Okay? Do Do you understand?
So, I think you're just kind of picking
what's comfortable for you regardless of
what her feet are doing. So sometimes
she's coming in and I me and sometimes
she's coming in in gaku me and you're
like I just I just like this way. Well,
she's always going to take that step and
you're not any closer to getting her off
balance. Do you see? Or whereas if you
go this way, you're much closer to
getting her off balance. Okay.
>> All right. To get myself in stupid
situations. Okay.
>> But when you're when you're here like
that, I don't want to go back towards
your hook.
>> Hi.
>> Okay.
>> So, let's put that foot there. Okay.
That way the camera can see it. So, I
don't want to come against your hook.
>> So, when you go to pull, right, you go
to pull. Do you understand? Okay, let's
start over. Okay. All right. So, she
goes to pull, then I'll go here.
>> Hi.
>> You see?
>> And I don't try to pull that back.
>> Hi.
>> I'll go. You go there. I go there. Then
this one takes over. Okay. Do you
understand?
>> Okay. You keep trying to hook. And then
this is what remember the last thing I
said was I try to get in weird
positions. Okay. All right. So if in
other words you guys know uh if you push
right do you understand?
>> Uh
I will get myself like you're driving
really hard. Okay. Then I'll get like
here. Do you see?
>> And I'll do it. But I don't I don't have
to do that. Okay.
It doesn't even look like she was
pushing. Okay. So likewise Okay. When
when she goes to grab,
it doesn't look like she was pulling
either. Do you do you understand? Okay.
So, now you go. Why?
>> Why?
>> You're not contesting.
>> Yeah. Cuz the all the energy is being
internalized. So, there's really no you
can't get in awkward positions. That's
why you do this. Okay. Do you got it?
So, what is happening here now is you're
uh you're getting in an awkward
position. not by conscious choice like
me.
>> So, it's probably you're watching me and
you're like thinking that was okay, but
I I'm not in any threat because go
because you pulled me to here. Do you
get that? I I am in the same grounding.
So, if she pushes from here, I'm in the
same thing. She pulls from here, I'm in
the same thing. Do you understand?
Whereas
when you getting pulled, you're like I
could see the tension and you're like
you got you're in the shoulders, your
foots off the ground. You're nowhere
near able to do anything. Okay. So the
advice I'm going to give you is as soon
as they touch, you're already
trying to find that same connection.
>> Hi.
>> Okay. So you have
>> you have these elements. Okay? So pay
attention.
>> You have uh a fire in.
>> Hi.
>> You have water out.
>> You'll have heaven up.
>> Hi.
>> You'll have earth down.
So to go max yang, you'd be what? Where
you think?
>> Uh heaven and up. Heaven, right? Up and
in. Up and in.
>> You got it.
Then out and down. Okay. Got it. So you
keep being on the table.
>> Okay.
>> So that's what I mean. Tensi or it's
heaven and earth. You see?
>> Okay. And now when she tries to shuffle
on this, that's where you are basically
doing the X pattern. Okay. Doesn't
matter. So boom.
Now it doesn't
Now it doesn't look like she's doing
anything other than coming in and
holding. Although we all know she's
pulling and trying to get her foot down.
Okay. All right.